what's up everybody that day trashy tour
is rolling on coming down to the wire
few shows left uh it's a mix of standup
comedy ay me and the big man co-
headline then we come out close the
shows out together playing a with the
crowd get your tickies yeah the Cub lion
gang we coming to Minneapolis Minnesota
Madison Wisconsin Milwaukee Wisconsin
Sacramento California Sacramento
California again you got two shows there
scoop them up San Francisco California
San Jose Washington DC and then we're
closing out the year with two shows at
the Filmore in Philadelphia the 21st is
sold out get tickets for the 20th and
come see the boys do it welcome to
another exciting edition of are you
garbage the show where you find out if
your favorite comedians are classy
individuals or absolute trash now here
are your hosts Kevin Ryan and H
Foley hey everybody out there and
welcome back to everybody's new favorite
podcast this is are you garbage it's
that little show we sit down to your
favorite comedians and we find out if
they up to be classy yeah Earth they
just a big old piece of trash trash
trash trash I'm your host St trolley
coming at you on a beautiful day we're
out back here at toties in the new
edition she's down there in the basement
with the plumber oh boy just trying to
get the boiler situated relax everybody
relax all right I did hear a little
knocking and banging he left his tool
belt upstairs
too this spoilers rocking baby don't
come knocking my co-host is coming at
you from across the table he is a CEO of
Ru garbage he's dressed like the n in on
the USS Enterprise right now you look
like the first guy killed in Star Trek
where'd you get that thing give it up
for KJ Kevin James Ryan Be Me Up Gippy
uh what's up everybody thanks for tuning
in as always please make sure you rate
review subscribe on iTunes full video
available on YouTube as you know those
numbers are TR up cooking then obviously
the greatest website of all time you go
over there you fall out your phone your
laptop
www.patreon.com
and let me tell you gang the army of
garbage is strong over there the homies
are strong over there on patreon gang it
really is not to be if you're not sure
what it is go take a gander at them
numbers over there there's a lot of
stuff going on over there you got videos
you got bonus episodes you got Vlogs you
got travel stuff I would put up nobody
puts out more uh patreon content than us
I'm going down I'm putting that down on
the on the wire right there really we're
doing you get you can get up to two
episodes a week we're always dropping
fun monthly stuff we got all the the
goals that we've hit the Disney the tour
the the shorehouse the shorehouse
there's live show live shows from The
Cruise live live shows from the cruise
we just did uh we had we have with uh
big J petley Mark Norman Shawn Patton
Jim Norton uh who else was on the other
one cyer sounds and Yanni Papito Johny
Papito yeah and now that I'm thinking of
it a couple of ticks left for that
second Philly show so scoop them up I
would get them now want all sellouts
they don't Patty's coming you know how
she can get man worse worse than you
couple of empty seats over there what
happened was there a pandemic or
something now did they pay you for this
[__] out of here [__] Flex on your
mom where did you get that jacket it's
got real ER nurse Vibes it's the same
jacket it's just the gray version of the
black one I wear okay it's just a little
newer it's not as uh broken in you know
what I mean all right you're about to go
to the dentist vibes okay what I don't
know go to the den is there Vibes for a
dude going to the dentist you're at the
dentist Toby where you at over here
[__] trying to [__] on this guy back
me up speaking of which I a nice quick
shout out to our producer extraordinaire
to magic man makes us all look good
works the ones the twos the threes and
the fours he crosses the t's and he gots
the dots the eyes he's got a brand new
pair of jeans on he's very excited about
give it up for T-Bone MC scruffs Toby
MCB everybody what up boys what up t-b I
got some new jeans yeah he's been he's
been walking around like your [__]
Cindy Crawford around his place I'm
looking sharp I he's got all black jeans
he's like do these look cool I'm like
there I didn't know you who knows well
I've been wearing the same pair of jeans
for about a year and a half sure I'm
right there with you yeah always one
pair of jeans two pair of jeans that's
all you need I bought three I felt like
a real hot shot same kind oh same size
same cut you know it baby where's a guy
like you get his jeans Old Navy really
yeah comfortable fit over there it's
mostly uh sweat material I know it's all
dork stuff but H&M they they they cut me
out buying the same pants for a decade
they stopped making my Styles cuz I'm
old now sure oh that hurts when you walk
in and people are like I'm like where
are your skinny jeans like kick rocks
not anymore dude everything's cut real
big Spen gifts beat it you look like
you're wearing your dad's clothes if you
go you go to an H&M anymore listen man
bagg of jeans stunk then and they stink
now yeah did I ever tell you the uh when
I when I first lost weight years ago I'd
gotten this this this is pre- comedy I'd
gotten really i' really porked up um and
uh and I lost I believe one half of the
story sure okay what that I really
porked up yeah that you did not lose it
I did because i' had been wearing dress
pants this is this is before I gained
the weight again I wor my my dead
uncle's dress pants when you met me uh
at the Raven down there in Philadelphia
but I'd been wear Dr like a homeless
businessman only guy I know show up in a
[__] 3/4 length coat with [__]
holes in his sneaks man I wish the long
coat would come back I really do it
never looked good on you I know it
didn't you just didn't I they don't look
good on me either you need a good you
need a specific frame and we ain't got
it running around like fat Batman dude I
loved it pop the collar up especially
the wool ones I'll take a number
four oh extra fries please they call me
the fart night
any who uh I had I I dropped a bunch of
weight and um I don't think I had
discovered Old Navy yet or something
like that cuz that was I I eventually
went there after this but I went to the
thrift store and bought a pair of jeans
and they fit really good and like a week
later I was with somebody and they were
like those are women's jeans there's no
pockets in the
back low rise I I can't think of the
name it was like it wasn't laye Bryant
but I sure it might have been or no um
uh it's on a tip Liz Clayborn they were
Liz Clayborn jeans in what world would
that be dude's pants that's crazy I
didn't look I was just excited that they
fit and I remember coming downstairs and
I was crying to show my dad I was like I
fit in them look at that and he was like
oh yeah they look
good is your boyfriend coming over to
dinner you're running around in 9xl
ladies jeans yeah I it took me like a
week you wearing fat chick jeans
it's the damn collection from lame
Ryan now is there a lot of junk in the
trunk here you're walking around in
apple bottom
jeans boots with the fur pair of juicies
they always look so comfortable I wish I
could have wore those juicies those
pants those sweatpants man when a girl
had those on dropped dropped when I was
in high
school were chicks walking around High
School wearing them oh yeah and you
everybody you like all the you were
probably dragging your desk around with
you in the wear my school bag in the
front no I'm cool man those things were
you're telling me dud man and these the
girls all like all the hot girls had a
specific like they knew they looked
really good in what like there was they
all had one so it would be like so and
so's wearing the yellow and they were
always crazy colors man those things
were all right those and I've said this
before solo yoga pants yeah they dropped
in high school too man I probably
shouldn't admit this still got a little
in the spank bank with those bad boys
Patty picked up a pair of them at some
point I swear to God she wore them like
once I was like don't ever let me see
you wearing them again she in a Trick
Daddy video what the
[__] Dam disg video vixen over here
shaking that back it up and dump it P
bending over in the kitchen grabbing the
cookie sheets was like Che
wh okay damn yeah never a thong you no
no I don't either one you yeah I don't
think anybody's moms are wearing thongs
got big it I European the broads wear
them the older broads wore them sure for
years my father-in-law
wears good guy hell of a keester on him
hey show it up rocket if you got it you
know what I mean man Shake Your Tail
Feather um yeah I put the kaios on that
real quick but your mom wearing thongs
no no the
[__] you dirty
[__] I got friends coming over no she
when she got a juicy uh cuz they became
cuz the the way it always works is cool
kids start wearing them and then it
filters in to the you know [__] DJ
Maxx and all that stuff and then
everybody starts wearing them sure you
know and I don't think she knew what she
was doing maybe she did I don't know
trying to get you a new
daddy out there trying to out there
trying father was alive and well you son
of a [__] hey don't blame me D blame
that trop of a mother but she was Patt
yeah she was kicking them and I was like
D no man yeah think I showed her like
the Flavor of Love or something she
stopped wearing them my uh my mom never
she never did it she never had any any
crazy uh she's always been you know a
bit reserved never
really never really showed it off a
little more Christian [__] Catholic
lady you know what I mean leave a little
bit of the imagination you know what I'm
saying can't be wearing booby tassels in
church
um uh I remember my mom will get frisky
every now and then and try like a
leather jacket or something and like you
know it's like a little too cool for her
could but like you're just like there's
usually something where I'm like that
was on sale Coal's yeah leather jacket
and a turtleneck something like that
with like like like an Irish cross some
sort of pendant or something there
usually a VI marcala coming behind that
somewhere I don't think she does checken
check yeah um dude that speaking of this
dude I went to my [__] uh I was down
visiting Denise and uh kill some time me
and the bird went to the mall that I
grew up going to mhm man those things
are got beat up here got be up there I
struck out here got a Sly over here s
press guys going where you been we're
tanking over here although I got to say
shout out to oxer Valley Mall out there
in like Langhorn or whatever it's
considered two Annie an's cooking the
rest of the walls collapsing Annie Ann's
got two locations they're in the Food
Corp prop then they got a satellite JN M
yeah it was all it was good but I mean
like empty you know malls are go doing
bad when stores are closing in them
before the mall closes oh yeah mall
closes is at like 9:00 so like oh we'll
swing over do a little you know little
window Sho and whatever and like stores
were closing up at like 6:30 on a Friday
night it's no good crazy you know what
Aunt Annie needs to do is they need to
get a a soft serve machine in there cup
little soft serve couple of them nuggies
around there home run sure I think this
one might have been connected to what
are they like the TCB y oh those the one
might have been a it might have been a
slash I remember my parents trying to
push that [__] on us when we were kids
instead of going to BAS Robins cuz they
thought it was healthier and this is
before they perfected the Greek frozen
yogurt this was just regular Frozen
Yogurt you were doing chains like that I
figured you wouldn't be like a we
weren't a chain ice cream fam off and on
Ras but if it wasn't re wasn't popping
yet I guess it was too yeah it was in
the '90s yeah when I was a kid we would
go to like you know enens salakos or
something like that some place some like
some local place in wilberry gotcha
there was a there was a place on 309 in
wilberry that had a huge cow
that's growth I didn't I didn't make the
joke could have been any one of your
family members like a huge cow it's
awesome awesome hard ice cream just your
mom and yoga pants all right but then
yeah we dab would go back and forth a
little bit we would do growing up New
Town had good nose which was it was like
the guy Coke
place they were good I think they still
might I don't know if they're still open
or not but uh that was like the local
Creamery or what like d that was a dairy
F had their ice cream same thing with uh
not Styers Tanner Brothers sure you go
there you get your [__] get get your
good good ice cream but no we went local
but you know we we' mix and matched
Baskin Robbins was big for us when we
were a kid we like that bubblegum ice
cream me and my brother n we never loved
it you ever have that yeah it's good I
remember the first time I went to
coldstone creamy with my family and my
dad thought the country was going to
hell I've never been never I went with
like a group of kids a group of friends
in like school like where there was like
half guys there was like you know five
of us like two or three girls and two or
three guys and someone's one of the
girls like let's go to coldstone cream I
walked in I'm like I ain't eating thisy
[__] yeah never [__] out of here oh
happy happy birthday like screaming at
you chopping up ice cream on a metal
slab the [__] out of here I'll be in the
I'll be in the car catching a heater and
listen as a fat guy sometimes you can it
can be too much [__] in there too much
too many toppings you get some kid all
smoked out I don't want him doing that
let them do do that [__] that back at
the lab I don't yeah I don't disagree
like Ben and Jerry give me the finished
product and they're almost hipping the
toe in the line of too much like they're
peanut butter cups it's too many and
they're whole [__] crack AER over
here hey goddamn break sure break that
[__] up a little bit The Briar did it
the best like three chocolate chips in
there that's it where can you see where
Briar it's do you know how to spell it
yeah I always felt like that was local I
felt like that was a Philadelphia thing
no can't be I I'm just saying like my
interpretation of it was that it was
local but I'm pretty I I know it's
National but where's it where's that
base data Brier's vanilla the vanilla
bean the little little specks in it yeah
thought we were French when that [__]
came out but they did have french
vanilla yeah no but remember my dad
throwing one of those out the back door
one time cuz it was like yellow oh yeah
it was like creamy oh no den he tried to
pull that one I said this looks like
mustard kick rocks I'll take I'll take
my Straight Up RS vanel all right
[__] doing his [__] with you all day
Philadelphia [__] knew it no [__] is
it a national brand now it's got to be
Briar yeah oh yeah we're Coast to Coast
now yeah we do jery we do Delaware we
need
Neapolitan uh damn one of my biggest
that for some I I feel like my dad told
me that one of my biggest regrets is
looking back in how uh Philadelphia has
all of the fattest foods out to it baby
that's why we love you biggest regret as
I look back and I always put my nose up
at the strawberry in the neopolitan I
still do it's it's awesome no it doesn't
get there fully it's not it's not enough
and it's it's too L it's too little give
me a berry taste not this like rose
waterer [__] pansy ass [__] N I
wish I would have shown a little more
love no the vanilla is the one that
stinks in the neopolitan that's crazy
talk that's C they're all good is what
you're you're supposed to go a cross
almost get like a spon I'm telling you
how you're supposed to eat it no we were
just little just little snots that that
strawberry would sit there and You' be
you'd be able to tell when you picked up
the thing cuz it' be it'd be yeah
lopsided we would get into the other one
I would open there would still be
strawberry left and I would crack a new
one oh that had to cause a war oh yeah I
mean at that point I didn't there was I
mean things at home were Rocky enough
that the [__] ice cream wasn't
getting you would have two two things of
ice cream in the house at the same time
I think my mom would buy like two yeah
oo never one that's it and then she
started moving over to edes remember
edies we had that for I thought that was
like rich people ice cream Ed cuz there
was commercials about it like that that
that felt like new money to me e Edy or
something right they might have done
yogurt it might have been frozen yogurt
too or she had some frozen yogurt in
house that was in a tall cylinder rather
than the tub yes 8s was that was like
rich people [__] to me I remember when I
was a kid and I used to watch uh family
ties and their ice cream was hogendas
and it was in the thing before I even
understood what hogendas was I was like
man they also had the orange juice in
the picture a family that did that I was
dad was a lawyer or something no one
does that that's only exist in
commercials no one's doing that I think
the only only reason we ever did it but
it was never in a nice glass it was
never in a it was in a [__] one
stained with like tomato juice or
whatever the plastic joint when Patty
would break out the frozen orange juice
yeah the concentr I mean that [__] yeah
of course that that's all we had growing
up man you want heartburn in first
period have a glass of that in the
morning I love that sh Yik loved it Jam
you up K but talk about bespoke post
shout out to the bespoke post box
awesome it's the holiday season and man
oh man do they know what they're doing
over there a Spoke post kippy's right's
talking about the Box awesome you like
doing cool guy stuff you like having
cool guy things around the house you got
grooming stuff you got outdoor stuff you
got stuff for the home bar look like a
real hot shot this holiday season and
get over there to a Spoke post and get
yourself a box awesome baby yeah it
shows up at your doorstep each and every
month so there'll always be something to
cheer you up when you need it I get it
and every time I come home I'm like ah
my I got the dog [__] on the rug again I
look over nice box of awesome open it up
Treasure Chest I get a knife I
start what no just in air I'm practicing
my moves obviously each each box is Val
Right Toby cut that each box is Valu to
around $70 but you'll pay a fraction of
that price plus with the box of awesome
you're supporting small businesses as $9
% of everything that comes from your box
of awesome is from a small upand
cominging brand get 20% off your first
monthly box when you sign up at box
ofawesome.com and enter the code garbage
at checkout that's box ofawesome.com
code garbage for 20% off your first box
box ofawesome.com code garbage do it
gang yep Kip this is Butcher box shout
out to the OG butcher box I'm not going
to pretend like you don't know what it
is but for any of the homies or bozos
out there that don't know it is heaven
on Earth amen sister send you meat right
to the house we're talking free range
talking wild caught salmon we're talking
grass-fed grass finish beef unbelievable
plus the deals they throw at this time
of year are absolutely Bonos yeah if
you're doing Thanksgiving dinner at the
house get yourself a butcher box get
that fresh turkey in there yeah you know
what you know what a pro move at
Thanksgiving is when you're talking
meats and stuff go hamburgers no going
Sloppy
Joe's you got the you got your
father-in-law coming over so you're
doing it throw some [__] cra legs at
him let him
know wow with the how's work going crab
legs and I'm having pull out the turkey
like a magic crack there you go and I'm
having sex with your daughter you'll
even get the recipe inspiration guides
tips everything you need to you need to
know to make the most out of your box
this Black Friday your search for
amazing deals on high quality protein
ends with butcher box they're offering
their best deal of the Year choose your
free steak for a year oh my God choose
between two New York strip steaks
flaming Ys or ribe eyes to get free that
you get free in every Bo for a whole
year when you join sign up today at put
that's crazy I'm signing up under a fake
name now sign up today at put Bo sign up
today at butcherbox.com and use code ay
to choose for your free stake for a year
and to get $20 off that's butcherbox.com
use code ay to get this special Black
Friday deal plus $20 off do it do it all
right gang but all that's neither here
nor there ice cream talk [__] OJ talk
aside let's [__] get cone I don't
know about you guys a couple of sprinky
a little bit of Dipping Dots uh I know I
had it once or twice it didn't like it
never got there again it would just like
they' freeze they were too too cold when
you got them that was sucker [__] that
was that was [__] for real poor kids at
the amusement park they thought they
were getting something they have it all
over their face and [__] like that I'm
not riding next to this guy it was all
Air I felt like it wasn't densing trash
yeah like eating [__] cold styrofoam
the the alltime H Foley content pitch
was us at some truck stop in West
Virginia in the middle of nowhere and
they had the knockoff dipin dots vending
machine and you turning around going
it's like diping dots I've never had it
could be a
video not saying I wouldn't kick the
tires a little bit but as nurse Kippy
said this is neither here nor there it's
a goddamn Family episode as you folks
know when you sign up for the old
patreon you get a question read on the
air yeah and let's get to it hit the
light uh this is from Chris Garcia back
this isn't even a qu I guess it is uh
this is from Chris Garcia yo what card
game does your family play play big
difference between Jin Ry and an UNO
family yes I still don't I still don't
know how to play Jin Ry I know how to
play Ry but that's not Jin Ry I knew how
to play Jin Ry um was when we did uh
arsonic and Old Lace at the hedro
theater we sat around a lot upstairs and
that's what we did why why the rest of
the play was going on with an old cop
played J taught us how to play Jin Ry
nice I couldn't remember it's something
with like matching numbers and [__] like
that yeah I mean that's what R Ry the
you know the spec you know how to play
Ry right regular r i don't believe so do
you no it's like we were not a we were
not a I thought that as like smart
households like when I would go over I
learned it yeah I learned it late I
learned it in like my junior high years
or whatever yeah this one kid I grew up
with they were twins they had like a
whole game room where they had like
Scrabble and Monopoly and all that stuff
we never we never had a pack of Uno
cards my cousins did but we never did
any of that stuff un we had Uno I guess
it was also you know at this point it
was probably when I was a kid it was way
more popular than when you we had Uno
everybody had Uno at in the N everybody
every family had an Uno deck we had
Battle Ship we had Monopoly but usually
led to a fight always and we had a we
had a game called The Flying finans
which was like mous trap it's a bunch of
drunk irish guys next door I'm pretty
sure I told you about that yeah no you
did uh [__] on me we had uh we had mouse
trap I don't think it ever got to work I
think I got it for Christmas I don't
think it ever worked I remember
something never got it together um and
then uh D I remember one time my buddies
this is when I knew that like you ever
like you're like friends with somebody
and then you go to their house and even
then like you know you're like oh we're
a little our families are a little
different but you know all in all still
the you know same how come nobody's not
yelling at everybody what's going on
dude we went over it's like a Saturday
you know and I'm like we're like young
teens 13 maybe something like that we're
like all riding bikes or skating or
something and we go in there and they're
like all right they their their their
day they were
spending was like hey your friends can
come over we didn't know like we got
there and they're like hey you can stay
but we're cleaning our board games what
the [__] so they took all the board
games out took inventory of all the
pieces taped the corners of the boxes
made sure the instructions was in dude I
was like me and Pat I was like dude
let's [__] let's go steal beer out of
their fridge and go to the woods dude
this [__] suck no way I'm sitting
here I don't even want to play Monopoly
let alone clean it grab her Pur let's
get out of here let's [__] steal the
silverware let's go to the [__] hit
the that's what I'm saying and I was
like oh we're not our families are not
the same no made you feel like a real P
always made me feel like a like a real
piece of [__] oh yeah like they were
like smarter and like they had like
structure time take it personally and
did I hold it in my head for 30 years
sure did as family their dog probably
had GL
bring my dog over and hump
you yeah like I remember these kids had
like series of like a series of books
like uh The Hardy Boys and stuff like
that and like Nancy Drew and all that
stuff and they would like have like
reading time and all that stuff uhuh it
was always a big especially start
hurting each other sure yeah what are we
doing here you got WWF on that thing
let's go uh it was always a big Telltale
sign too of somebody build a fort let's
go of the classiness of of the family of
where uh in the '90s obviously where the
video games were hooked up and the and
where the computer was right if the
video games were on the main TV just
like on the living room floor I was a
pretty trashy family sure I me same
house we'd go over and before like
anybody before people would have like a
TV in the other room or the bedroom or
the basement or whatever they dude they
would unplug it wrap it up coil it up
put it away every single time we're like
dude Sega lived on my family room floor
for
[__] 10 years probably or whatever
and they were like no we'll put it away
and you can play for an hour or whatever
I was like dude this is [__] yeah to
same M though would try to give you
apple slices with a sandwich dude she
tried to I'm not even joking she gave me
guava juice one time and dude I was like
I almost [__] spitted at her I
remember my buddy's like you don't like
guava juice I'm like dude where the [__]
are we get me the [__] out of here guava
I still ain't never had guava juice can
I get a a class versus Trash rating on a
on a on a move I've been seeing recently
uhhuh how do you guys feel about eating
an apple with a knife oh it's great
slicing it up apple slices now it's nice
in public what are you a Rancher that's
crazy a bad guy from Dennis the men
that's how he scared the [__] out of me
that was Christopher Lloyd I know I saw
a guy on the street with a pocket knife
just carving up he's trying to be
somebody he wants that to be his
personality that's like with stuff that
he does you know what I mean you think
stuff's interesting about you that's not
really interesting yeah not that though
I could see you getting into like
flipping a big coin yeah exactly and be
like oh what oh this thing and then not
want to talk about it but keep bringing
it up I did want to get into I'll be
like why you doing that oh what do you
mean I always flip a coin I did want to
get into those balls for a while you
know the the the big they look like big
marbles that guys s Chinese things yeah
the Buddhist things I wanted to get into
those for a little while sit there and
think you ever run around
McDonald's or Burger King McDonald's or
Burger King cuz Lawrence Fishburn used
them in um boys in a hood I always
thought that was real cool you would
just sit there contemplate yeah
contemplate mle over some stuff hide
nothing to mle over though did you did
you ever run around were you ever a
toothpick guy no I tried we weren't
toothpick guys but we were I tried as a
kid um as a kid as a okay I was a
pocketknife guy too as a kid for a while
in the early 2000s my brother got into
the Australian toothpicks the ones that
have like tea tree oil on them we we
were rocking those for a little bit not
cooler I don't know what that is but
that's not just trying to import a
personality oh man cuz you know that's
getting shot where you got a toothpick
where you had a dinner earlier nah these
are from Australia you're really shoving
that in yeah I can't remember why when I
was a little kid I I I wanted to be a
wheat in- the- mouth guy what you know
what I'm talking about a straw hat no
like was it the 1300s little stalk yeah
trying to rock that for a little bit it
was just weeds though cuz there was no
weed why you wanted to tell people that
town was back at that away where you
want to go as you tap you tap on the
roof of their car oh you're lost boy
I've always wanted to tell someone that
someone's been dead for 33 years that
house burned
down oh man I like oh as documented I
had a lot of those things that I thought
were cool the devil sticks [__] hacky
sack I did a pocket watch for a couple
of months Jesus
Christ that's dude that's such a you
like I'm not even shocked that is a you
thing yeah you really like after college
I like got one I wanted one for
Christmas and I got one for Christmas I
had I had no vest to put it in though
yeah that's that's your problem that you
can't tell
time zero shot that thing was correct
yeah sure
yeah wanted to rock a pocket watch I
wish all that stuff would come back stop
serving breakfast in 30 minutes we
better go take my weed out good Lord
instead of a picture of your sweetheart
back home with just a Big
Mac there she
is walking around like fat ass Bentley
it's a fonsworth B I knew that wasn't
going to play that's a good that's a
good question though that is a big
determination sure but I it wouldn't be
that's also the same thing as like is
uno trashy yeah it's not classy I
thought that was like smart people stuff
that was always in like something like
that with like a couple golf pencils and
stuff where they would write down their
scor well you didn't have to keep
scoring who know it was just whoever got
out I don't know but like all the other
games and stuff I think card games are
traditionally classy a Ry it takes skill
it takes time it's you know we didn't
even play Life my cousins had life I
thought that was the coolest thing ever
dude that's that reminded me like Ser I
I didn't get that that seemed like
something you would play in elementary
school getting married and [__] kid
having kids buddy put a dragon in here
or something what are we doing [__] I
didn't understand that either and I
still don't I hated it on the the little
people in the cars freaked me out yeah
they did the little just riding off to
death know no face on them or nothing
yeah like cards are like you know life
insurance and
J buddy I got my own problems my
daughter's Knocked Up Jesus Christ no I
was going to say I'm being audited what
I hated it on the low but I did always
want to know how to play Dungeons and
Dragons I assume you were probably a
champion I'm a d and d man myself really
that's from Airhead shout out to
Airheads great movie Very underrated
movie by way did you play Dungeons and
Dragons I've been known to Adventure
sure really were you a magic I tried
magic but I couldn't understand it
didn't get it weird dice too expensive
and I didn't understand the game is it
magic like the stores where you go in
they look like toys there's like castles
and figurines no that's Workshop dudee
man those places were I wanted to take
one of those home and just have at it
imagine a bunch of high 15-year-olds
stumbling upon one of those in the
Franklin Mills mall and and the weirdos
did they make any money and the weirdos
that work there really those figurines
are incredibly expensive plus you got to
buy the paints the paints it's it's a
whole wait the paints you you have to
paint all that [__] yourself get the
[__] the fun of it that's why I hate it
models just give me the goddamn thing I
don't want it to put it together it's
never going to look like on the box yeah
you're not in it for model the people
that are in it for that stuff is they're
in it for the making of it that's crazy
the tinkering the painting put a new veg
on him goober Ville yeah man we laughed
in this dude's face I felt so bad you
know when you're like I'm being mean but
this he's like this is GLE the king of
or whatever and dude was like me Pat and
Vinnie with the skinny high as a kite
being like what the [__] dude we went
back and found our other buddies like
you got to see these losers times your
mom picking you up dude oh man it was
rough I didn't get that and I didn't get
the um remember the uh like the uh
Revolutionary War soldier figurines that
people would have no you guys know what
I'm talking about they would paint them
similar Vibes [__] out of here be a
goddamn [__] gii Joe I'm gonna really
regret admitting this but so the game
that they play Games Workshop is called
Warhammer and there was a
spin-off of they made a Lord of the
Rings game and I played that one and I
got all the figurines and I would paint
them and the Warhammer wait you'd have
to do all this [__] just to play the
game yeah and what about like the
castles and stuff cuz those things were
pretty sweet how'd you fit that in your
schedule with all the chicks you were
back Jesus Christ dude making toys and
how did you paint when you were stuffed
in a locker wasn't the light really bad
get in there I did it by feel yeah it
was really that's crazy all of all of
the the Warhammer guy dorks would make
fun of us they were like we were even
lower on the to Totem ble horrible
Dungeons and Dragons seemed like it was
actually kind of cool oh dungeons
dragons is fun for a minute I got into
uh about that I read only one of the
books it was called Dragons of Autumn
Twilight do you know what I'm talking
about it was some like series it was
very similar to Dungeons and Dragons it
was like old timey [__] like like Lord
of the Rings which I [__] love those
movies sure they're kill mean the movies
that they made that spent like $400
million making yeah they're all right
yeah they did they did okay they're good
stuff [__] what's his name vgo
mortensson
goddamn hero put it back in your pants
will you big
guy uh all right let's see um great
question I just want to say great
question great question great question
did you guys play Simon nope moving on
I'm kidding you know what I'm talking
about oh yeah real easy for 5 seconds
then completely impossible I know S I
think spazzed out on you talk about
[__] early AI thing had it in for you
you didn't play that no was P that was
after that was before my time a little
bit you know what else [__] give me
gave me just made me sad light bright I
loved light bright I could never do it I
would just put all the see I had all
that stuff ster I was too stupid to do
it I didn't understand where to put the
things it didn't make any sense but it
was very comforting to have that on that
was like that was like a nightlight for
me with the different colors and stuff
like that I put it on my room I think I
didn't like mine cuz mine was you like I
got mine from my cousin it was like a
hand me- down it was like it was a clown
or something and it just [__] gave me
the Hebb G I used to keep it in the
laundry room I didn't like it I didn't
like it anywhere near me or my other
toys wait why the light Bri yeah just
[__] creeped me out we had I had
speaking spell I was a big speaking
spell kid you guys are probably too
young for that yeah speaking spell was
sweet is that explains why you talk to
text all your text messages no you had
to type it in oh was the reverse yeah
yeah it wasn't you didn't say something
we had that technology back then goddamn
shuttles are blowing up in the sky
[__] jammed up I had that [__] back
there dude [__] hemmed up uh we had
what do you want to remember these you
had spell master or word Master do you
remember those they were like it sounds
like the world's lamest Superman
villain uh it's actually an i instead of
an
e what's the superpower he's kind of a
dick spellmaster word
Master
pterodactyls
[__]
it was a handheld spell checker for
class like before computers and word
processing MH so like if you were like
how do you spell dictionary you would
hand they would give you like a [__]
game boy type thing and you would try to
spell it out and it would correct it for
you okay so you're like writing in class
or whatever well you had have one of
them you pass it around in class one it
was called like spell master or game
master or something didn't they kind of
give up on spelling wasn't there wasn't
at a certain point they kind of just
said
there's no no points for spelling why do
I feel like I remember that at some
point I don't think so they just kind of
gave up on you weren't going to lose
points for spelling that sounds like if
you got held back the entire School
District was going to get knocked for
their life yeah like you were low you
were lowering the bell curve so much
that they were like all right guys we
can't hold we can't hold iing lose our
tater tots
[Laughter]
contract I could have swore that kind of
that kind of happened at some point no
points for spelling or something I think
how do I feel like I remember hearing I
remember in college I feel like that was
a thing like like the cool professors
would be like I don't care if there's a
grammatic error or a spelling error in a
15-page paper like it's more about your
thoughts and the content and the what
you know what I mean it's like yeah
Hemingway didn't use any grammar he was
a goddamn genius he was a drunk and you
know
it blew his brains out all over Key West
but he was a genius him and them goddamn
cats anybody with that many cats is
weird how dare you goddamn National
Treasure that
man uh all right this one's from
Benjamin H I've never thought about this
but how garbage is it to take your shoe
off in public to get a little rock out
that's been bugging you man you lose all
confidence when you got to take your
shoe off in the side on the sidewalk man
that's so F you're like I always get a
rock in my shoe always do it's like the
goddamn Rockies in there especially my
Crocs I get them in oh there's hole he
can come in from all angles Jam you up
man there's something about you got to
lean on something take it off shimmy it
back on yeah I remember I did a play in
college and I was supposed to have a
limp in the thing and you trying to get
back in acting it's the third time you
plugged your
resume but I was supposed to I was
supposed to have a limp and I put a rock
in my shoe a real method huh ended up
hurting
myself
God
cut cut cut God damn
it gave yourself planner fasciitis to be
salesman number two something like that
dude really hurt for like a couple of
months CU I came down on it
hard now was
anyone CU now you have a close circle of
you know relatively aware people me who
kind of you know like you're kind of
corralled within your decision making
now a little bit you know what I mean of
like kind of you know how like you
sometimes you come in with a sounds like
an insult no no no no not at all not at
all you're a you're a creative man in
some senses and you're like you
sometimes you'll come in you like hey
I'm going to do this Toby goes I don't
think that's a good idea who was
checking you or were you just kind of
unchecked back in the
day uh because it wasn't until very
recently that you started bowling with
bumpers yeah well that's a great way to
put
it what do you
mean I don't know what you mean you know
how you have now you have a but I've
taken it as disrespect it's not it's not
I just wanted who was the Inner Circle
previous to this Inner Circle creatively
anything wise I don't know I don't I I
don't understand what you mean if you
were going to make a big decision in
your life when you were let's say 30 27
uhuh who were you sounding that off with
like what would be a big decision
I don't know but I mean getting into
pocket watches and long coat yeah that's
what I'm saying yeah there was nobody
all right nobody putting rocks in your
shoes to be a better actor moving in
North Carolina all that [__] yeah
obviously nobody
[__] just ask him [__] guy with
rocks in his shoes walking down whing to
North Carolina with a pocket
watch [__] idiot a long coat on in
the middle of
August planting palm trees on the beach
yeah
no okay I mean I did have some people
that made fun of me pretty
heavily have their numbers I'd like to
talk to them I had a roommate that that
used to make fun of me pretty heavily
for for for music and stuff like that
yeah I feel like you're talking about me
you talking about the years we live
together no
no used to have roommate stifled my
creativity big head
manscaped manscaped manscaped is Italian
for a keep it a nuts a clean you know
what I'm saying gang it's the holiday
season people are going to be opening
presents if you know what I mean people
get loose under that missl toe get that
eggnog in him you don't want to go down
to be like yikes what the hell is that
so clean them up and freshen them up
everything you need they got over there
at manscape you got the what the new
performance package fivepoint Ultra five
the ultra they're doing that's already
out comes with the lawn mower 5.0 Ultra
body trimmer the weed whacker 2.0 ear
and nose hair trimmer then you got the
crop smoother aftershave lotion for the
nuts I'm not talking about chestnuts
roasting on an open fire either gang uh
the L mow 5.0 truly does it all it comes
with two about balls on your forehead it
comes with two blade heads a standard
trimmer blade foil blade uh for a super
smooth finish uh this performance
package has everything you need to shape
up look feel and smell amazing get 20%
off plus free shipping with the code
garbage at manscape.com that's % off
with free shipping at manscape.com and
use the code garbage gang do it do it K
let's tell him about Aura Oh you mean AA
frames the gift everybody's getting this
year from old kiino everyone's getting
that let me tell you something you got
the frame you throw it on the you throw
it on an end table or something like
that you get to load up pictures people
can load them up and they send it and it
keeps going it's fresh I it's like a
little NightLight it's very warming and
cozy when I walk into the kitchen at
night to get my glass of water or milk
or have my cheesecake or your Hooch and
I need a little stiff drink to take the
edge off of a long day of podcast
there's the kids playing H Little League
or whatever right there yeah I get drunk
and watch mine it's like you're at the
movies they're absolutely fantastic guys
do yourself a favor you get to stay in
touch with your family if they don't
live near you it's a really nice thing
they were named number one best digital
frame by wire cutter and they're really
a really thoughtful gift to give that'll
bring them Joy all year long it's one of
those things people open up and go oh
and you go hey send you pictures look
and see
it's fantastic um from now through Black
Friday uh and Cyber Monday Aura is
offering their best deal of the year for
a limited time so don't wait listeners
can save on the perfect gift by visiting
Ora frames.com garbage that's Aura Au
frames.com garbage use promo code
garbage to get $40 off their bestselling
frames terms and conditions appli do it
now back to the show back to the show
this one's from Josh $10 homie haven't
had one read yet shout out to you is it
is it garbage if my family started going
to Ponderosa Steakhouse after watching
news coverage of the DC sniper shooting
that happened at one of them delicious
spot by the way rip
Ponderosa I mean I think it's well
documented how I feel about Ponderosa I
don't think I know I don't think I've
never even been you're crazy there was
one right up the street from us and we
would go as kids like 10 of us and their
clothes now yeah and get like two plates
was it a buffet style yeah it was a
legendary Buffet really they're all
closed oh I'm I'm not sure about that
Toby would have to give a Google on that
they might be maybe one or two are
hanging around there's always one or two
lingering around somewhere but they were
they were incredible yeah they're still
banging are they really yeah I would
love to go to that well this looks like
it's in someone's house though that
might not be correct that just a p
that's that's that's literally like a
yeah that's not that's why that's where
I began my love affair with ranch
dressing was that a Ponderosa really
yeah mhm yeah we never did that that it
was always Italian at my at my parents
the Italian and the wishbone yeah and
the clear Shaker and then that was the
first time we kind of got wind of uh of
ranch ran a salad with uh tomatoes and a
bunch of cheddar cheese and some black
olives and ranch dressing sure with a
[__] thing of chocolate pudding just
slapped on the side let's go love them
they were great yeah there a bunch
banging really mhm got to hit one of
those um I we were very and I think this
comes from like my
mom being poor and then you know having
some like she didn't want to be poor we
were we never went to a buffet ever and
looking back now that what I know about
her I think it was a very like we are
not we do not need to do this we are not
I can afford to buy my children food
same exact thing with my family that's
crazy never once a good value I'm not
saying it's not I'm listen you're I'm
not [__] on it or [__] I'm
saying I think my mom was very weird
with stuff like that you're ready to go
to war for the buffet Jesus I'm not
saying buffets aren't good I ate at one
last week I'm just saying I think my
where' you go my mom was very um like
hey I don't need to go to a buff it was
like an emotional thing for her I do I
remember I went to a buffet or Ponderosa
a buffet I love a buffet love a buffet
because I can get the fat kid food that
uh you can't order all at once what was
the where else are you going to get
spaghetti General SAU chicken that's
that's what I'm saying and and not
[__] not filling up my play with some
[__] vegetables I don't want General
SAU chicken and mashed potatoes with a
little bit of mac and cheese had had a
[__] smash some fries on there so
good maybe a slice of Z where was the
buffet on the cruise it's like it's like
you're tearing down the borders of the
world yeah yeah it's the way it should
be I'm for World way it should be man as
long as that country is America cuz it's
all hamburgers hot dogs french fries and
pizza cuz I just saw I saw a thing on
Instagram one one of the homies sent it
to me um about Wendy's Buffet which was
like
$3 and they had don't remember they had
Mexican food they had Italian and then
they had a salad bar and man that was
crazy and a baked potato station I
believe so good so good yeah I remember
that I I feel like I remember the baked
potato I feel like that's all I ever saw
at the one there was only one Wendy's in
my area um that I'm pretty sure still
banging what was the where was the
buffet on the cruise that you didn't
tell me about where you got piz what do
you mean I didn't tell I didn't I didn't
not tell about it you guys purposely
withheld that information from me no we
didn't uh you went there without me you
had a show me and Big Jay went okay yeah
I didn't not tell you you left to go to
a show me and Jay had lost all our money
at the blackjack table we said let's go
stuff our face with hamburgers was it
nice uh it was pretty good uh I think I
did some uh I definitely did some fries
I think I did a hot dog fries couple
slices of pizza buffet that's whack what
what are you doing it wasn't that great
oh okay I mean like it depends when you
hit it too I was also [__] probably
20 beers deep at that point I'm not
looking for [__] chicken tikka masala
or something you know what I mean that
would a side of mashed potatoes I needed
something to sober up everything should
be over mashed
potatoes kind of putting that down now
so nice in the middle of the plate pour
whatever it is over top you know it's
really good spaghetti sauce over like a
meat sauce over mashed potatoes instead
of spaghetti I can see that kind of like
a shepherd's pie yeah yeah I'm all right
with that that's how my aunt did
shepherd's pie it was with it was a red
sauce red sauce wrong as [__] it's a red
sauce cheddar that's how she did
spaghetti what with
potatoes it was mashed potatoes
basically like a meat spaghetti sauce
and cheddar cheese over top wo shout out
to my mom my uh my in-laws are in town
from Germany and her dad is a great cook
he does a goulash that'll [__] knock
your socks off Patty does a goulash but
they make he hom makes these uh they
call them dumplings or like I think in
German it's like canoodles or something
like that canoodle and dude it's like I
don't know what it is it's like
flour potato something and are they
almost like little
tortellinis no they're like uh the
Polish do something like that called
goami which is really clean it up if too
sounds like a bad case of
swampass ah got
goomies
uh it's pretty good German canoodle yeah
it's these German bread
dumplings let me see nah I don't know
that man they're
[__] fantastic oh he makes them
[__] homemade he's in there German up
the kitchen oh man and then you [__]
take like two or three of those put them
on the plate you fry them up a little
bit hard you get a little crust on them
and [__] a big spoonful of goulash
bet your mom walks in there singing
America the Beautiful huh dressed as
Uncle Sam
but setting up fireworks in the
K clean that [__] up I got a pizza
coming uh all right this one's from
T-Bone cams.com shout out to you first
time long time Canadian shareholder here
there you go shout out to our friendly
Neighbors in the north is it garbage you
use a shop vac in your apartment nothing
is Left
Behind as the vacuum yeah they're pretty
good they're good but they're not uh's
the problem they're not mobile that way
they're they're clunky they're clunky to
use and they're not detailed they're
like they're like it's like using a
[__] a bomb instead of a sniper rifle
you know here's the problem with that if
ever at any time that shopback was used
to clean up uh
drywall oh that that dust is gets
everywhere yeah you ain't lying and
they're brutal to clean and you're
getting sick sure when you clean that
you're get you're getting a [__]
sinus infection sure I got one at the
house now they always they're always
miss in a wheel yeah they're always
[__] up and then you drag them the
hose isn't long enough the cord's not
long enough it's like very pulls out you
[__] lose it oh man it sucks but a
fresh one that's the type of dude who
like someone spills a drink and he goes
Check It Out shop back wet and dry you
know I mean we have a we have a Dyson
man and I tell you it's it's crazy how
good this thing is it's nuts and it's
real low too like it doesn't make a lot
of noise it's real slow yeah man I
remember we got our suck your nose hairs
out we got our uh basement refinished at
my mom's at Denise's house you know
[__] uh it's probably like 2000 or so
this is probably the third time we had
it finished I think we got it we my
uncle Den was doing it for a long time
and I think he like picked up another
job or like the ran out of money or some
we ran out of money or the divorce
something happened where it was
partially finished and then it kept
flooding bad Su pump kept flooding and
then we finally were like dude we had
this uh they got this carpet installed I
it was like baby [__] Brown it went the
whole basement was that color and it was
like waterproof or something where if
you spilled you could just like vacuum
it up with the shop vac a that wasn't
good for your skin dude we had a party
and we got it we got the carpet done
like minutes before the party like that
was like the the end date we got to get
the you had a family party or you and
your friend no family party I was 12 or
13 or whatever or everyone's coming over
so when it the whole it might have been
like Christmas or something we were
hosting it that year so it's like a 100
people like 60 kids running around the
whole nine yards and man I was showing
off that you could just spill water I
remember I was just dumping Coke on the
road being like it's okay you vacuum it
up my mom's like what the [__] are you
doing these carpets are like three hours
old I did that to my dad's new car with
a with a blizzard one time a blizz Oh I
thought you meant the storm cycle I was
like Jesus Christ now the the ad
campaign for blizzards at Dairy Queen
cuz they were so thick you could turn it
upside down and I did that on August
afternoon I did it at my dad's car man I
man talk about ruining this poor guy
Sunday just trying to take his kids to
get ice cream Jam him up I remember
being in the parking lot of 7-Eleven and
him cleaning it out just [__] losing
it and plus I was out the goddamn
blizzard they W going back I was trying
to be a [__] hot shot in the back
seat did either of you guys ever have
the the anti- stained pants same thing
where the water would beat off oh what
the [__] that's terrible welder talking
about I remember like Dockers a lot a
race car
driver stain [__] I had him and I
remember I remember pouring water my
beads cuz it beads right off but why
would you get why did you get them
because I'm better than everyone else
dude I'm stain proof dude crazy the
[__] I didn't like that material against
my skin so when the bullies dumped the
lunch on his head it wouldn't ruin his
pants again joke t You My Mother stain
proof my pants this is my third wedgie
of the day I'll have you
know um yeah well like a lot of those in
the to that came out with that stuff
like the Dockers and all that had the
shirts that you know you can like
[__] but they there's like a film on
it it's not je sucked I don't know I
don't I don't think Dockers suck too
they never I don't mean to disparage a
great americ huge in the crotch I like I
felt crotch was like 2 feet long down to
my knees they I feel like they were
either meant for guys in real good shape
or fatties for guys that were that were
definitely going over the gut you were
going over the gut I don't disagree with
that that's why I feel like there was so
much space in the hi area and the pleats
I couldn't figure any of that out of why
my pants didn't look like Michael J
Fox's when he wore like a pair of tan
pants on on TV what it was and I could
never figure it out and then slowly you
realize well your mom is a crease going
straight down the middle and they're
pleated pleated pain that's where
they're like ribboned yeah at the waist
at the top like like Zoot Suit yeah it
sucked well it's that's kind of coming
back again but for a long time it wasn't
the flat front was and I same thing I
didn't know I think it was in college or
something I like the flat front just
regular pis of course um I had a pair
from Old Navy that were awesome wore
them forever till they ripped in the
cratch I showed up to a job usually how
they ended up I showed up to a job
interview with a pair of slack pleated
gray slacks cuz I didn't have a suit so
I just do pleated gray slacks they were
Club room for Macy's probably like1 1999
Club room's all right Club room's all
right um I had a couple of Club room
shirts from my uncle it's the lower
level real classy it's the no it's not
it's the lowest level with the little
with the little scissors and sewing kit
on there I don't know Club room that's
not good club foot
maybe Club you're halfway in the country
club with those things no club haering
for a turkey club and Bloody Mary is the
lowest level of ma of the Macy's Brands
I think it's club club room Inc never
heard of them that was that was for
[__] I used to like Alini Al no so
this is what I went alen was a big
alfini guy me and my brother had a
couple of alen button Downs short sleev
also sounds like a kid you grew up with
shout out to alfini ladies and
gentlemen the youngest of the feny boys
got run over by a
deer dude the alfini benefit it went
Club room Al I forgot about I knew I was
missing one we thought we were wearing
Italian you couldn't tell me [__]
meanwhile it's probably made in Vietnam
that material was all right I dude I had
a corduroy I had a tan corduroy blazer
Ali man I got it on my corduroy blazer I
got it on I looked like Mr feny
dude Mr Matthews dude corduroy Blazers a
dumb look I and then I had an AR I I
think I might have met I had an AR I
spent all my money on this to wear what
I it was on a mannequin when I was
working at Macy's and I was like I gotta
be that guy dude I bought the Argyle
Sweater black Argy sweater I had the
coll the white collar shirt on dur it
where you going and a flask full of
Canadian Mist I bet no I went to a like
a dive bar called Lucy's it was on
second in Market I showed up and
everybody was like what the f wait why
why were you dressed up I I was trying I
thought I was that's what you did I had
[__] I remember this older cool dude
made fun of me heavy it's like older
rich guy was like oh I love this or
something like rolled his eyes and
walked in I had boot cut boot cut uh
Express jeans on with like with with
like designs on the on the pockets good
pair of Jord
dashes showing off that a yeah man it
was uh it was a rough dressed like a
teacher they're more like a TA yeah yeah
yeah I was I was shadowing the teacher
for the day man you know was it tough
look the short sleeve or the no sleeve
uh
sweater the sweater vest no but not
buttoned there was no buttons wait say
that again short it was a sweater v-neck
but no sleeves sweater vest that's a
sweater vest I thought it was I thought
a sweater vest had to have the buttons
on no no that would be a sleeveless
cardigan that' be a SLE which I don't
think exists a sleeveless cardigan cut
that let's get on that yeah no aard a
bad idea a cardigan buttons uhhuh I had
there's pictures of me in a [__]
thinking it was cool I had the long I
wore Cardigans I Kurt Cobain I wore them
all the time no I'm talking sweater
vests oh I had the long white T-shirt
under it and an Old Navy [__] sweater
vest man there was these two cool kids
down the shore when I when I was going
when I was oh yeah all right now I know
what you're talking that's all right
that was the same time it was cool to
have keys on a lanyard sure them bad
boys around two Tre there was guys them
know what's up there was guys that could
just pull this off yeah it wasn't us and
and and you thought that it looked cool
on them like the way like the way Brad
Pit dressed in Fight Club like sure
there was there was when I was a
freshman there was a senior this guy
Andreas Gainer he was literally like a
god he was he was built like an Avenger
and he used to wear like the Adidas
sweatpants but like the satin ones with
like a sweater and man this guy could
pull it the [__] off yeah it's not us
and you just think yeah he does it why
can't I do it you didn't realize you end
up looking like Mr feny dude yeah that's
the problem dude he's named after back
flips going forward yeah that's the
coolest guy coolest name ever yeah had
to do a half Gainer out the window it's
the first time I ever heard the term
Gainer was was working with a east of
valet cars at a Toyota dealership and
there was a retired uh fire fighter and
we're like hey you ever have to jump out
of window and he goes one time I had to
do a half Gainer out the window I was
like d I don't know what the [__] this
old man's talking about but he sounds
like a b did a half Gainer out the
window your sweater V look
cool it's some nice looking pleat
son but I do I remember showed up in
pleat and I remember looking everybody
was dressed I think it was like my
brother my cousins I got some
good-looking dude cousins who dress real
nice right you know like fashion forward
my brother was of those guys and I
remember sitting there I looked like an
accountant and they were you know
modelesque might might as well been
compared to me and I remember looking
I'm like what the why don't I look that
cool and I was scanning their pants and
I get to mine dude I got like seven
pleats in the front I look like a
goddamn pirate dude it was [__]
horrible dude that outfit that you
pieced together for that Hail Mary job
was it was sink or swim oh in I think
just just in general when you were like
waiting tables when you tried to put on
when you scraped something together from
your dad and your brother and your
cousin and this one just to try to just
let me flush this down one time let me
look I'll never get jammed up again you
know what I would do a lot when I didn't
I didn't have a suit like I had these
Brown Club or these Brown These gray
Club room pants I had a button up like a
plain white button up [__] yellow ass
ring around the neck you know what I
mean um and a tie and I would wear I had
like a old Navy or like a gap short like
kind of like this but a peac coat you
know like those black short length peac
coats that are just you know like a
regular just black and I would wear that
try to fool them that that's like my oh
like I you know I'm not wearing a I'm
not I'm not wearing a suit but this kind
of looks I was outside meanwhile keep
your winter coat on for the whole
interview meanwhile it's July I'm
[__] Shing yeah man I know exact I
never felt comfortable in that stuff in
the winter you were always freezing cuz
it all got the air got in there thin
that material is so goddamn thin it's
like gabardine we wore something like
that we were both kind of dressed like
that when we did that Christmas show
right before we moved up here I was
dressed exactly I was wearing those Club
room pants a white button up a tie mhm
and that jacket talk about a Hail Mary
the whole ship would have been sank if I
didn't get that check yeah I know but
look at us now boys there you go uh by
all the pleated pants we
won they're coming back
and that's the problem we can't wear
know I know like you were just saying I
went to H&M when I was in the mall
everything's like cool guy hip baggy cut
and I look I look like a schlub when I
got to go to I need tight clothes Old
Navy the epicenter of dorom to get my
pants you know it's over though that's
not true it is Old Navy has never once
been cool ever dude it's not no but
nobody knows their Old Navy jeans and
all Navy jeans are comfortable and great
and affordable he's not [__] on them
why are you taking offense to all these
weird things he's not [__] all them
he's and now literally hundreds of
thousands of people know
yeah I can't wait till the next live
show sweet Old Navies
dude but what would be cool lies I got
lies I got lies on now I don't know I
asked the I asked the guy in the the the
guy in the stock room had real cool
pants you hanging out back there not the
soccer the Chang the Chang the changing
that's even worse yeah what do you mean
and he started he started head under
Shar what are those he started wait he
worked at Old Navy yes okay but he had
real cool pants on and he started I was
like where where are those from those
are like the the cut I want you know but
they had a but they were like all ripped
and cool he didn't buy them there no he
didn't he started naming stuff I
pretended like I wrote it down but I was
like I'll never go I'm not cool enough
you are there's like there's an
apostrophe in it or something I'm out
yeah it was like it was called like
Sheen or something no I got the Old
Navies oh gap's all right Gap was I
don't know what they are now but back in
the day they were the epitome of cool
they're still they I mean they're not
they still hold their for like their
basic for like PA Gap buttonfly jeans
look out yeah cleaning up didn't I give
you that pair of that remember I gave
you that pair of expensive Gap jeans the
svage denim yeah remember that I got
this they almost were like waterproof
they were
thi thick yeah it's like it was Japanese
Salvage Denim and I got them on sale
they were like 80 bucks or something man
you couldn't tell me [__] and then I
lost weight and gave them to you yeah I
fitting them for about two weeks man but
he wore them he probably slept in those
things he was showing up putting his
showing them all Salvage denim CU that
was the first pair of jeans that I had
that were cuffed at the bottom they were
pre-cued and they had that red they
Salvage has that red little line on the
edge they look real nice sitting on top
of a pair of sneakers yes yes they did
look at Tippy pants now we don't have to
sheare pants no
more you've been away a long time we
don't share pants no
more we've been working real hard for a
long time we have to share clothes but
sometimes we do sometimes we do just to
feel close to each other
still um all right let's see here this
is from dickpic and oix shout out to you
$10 chump uh can you open a door $10
chump yeah that's all right could you
open a door with a credit card right now
if you needed to without the door really
I lived in an apartment Chicago for 5
years didn't have a key for maybe two of
them no [__] yeah back door right in
baby but it's really dependent upon the
door it 100% depends upon the door most
most of the doors now they've figured
that out there's like a lip the door has
to close towards the outside it can't
open out it has to open in so that yes
you can get behind it and pull well if
you want to get behind it and pull you
have to cut the card and so that you can
slip it over and pull it but most of the
time you just want to just slap it in
let you right in because the one side of
the thing it's sloped yeah you have to
slide it in yeah yeah yeah yeah an
interior door forget I get through that
like butter remember I don't for us it
was big uh I guess cuz there was like a
when we moved to Bucks County there was
a lot of newer construction so like all
the door locks that were on top of the
door jam did you have that all the door
locks so like in like new homes right
you know how like uh an interior like a
bedroom door yeah just has a little hole
on it to unlock it yeah you can poke it
with the with a pin yeah yeah yeah of
course well when all those houses were
built they put all the there's like an
actual key for that yeah they would put
it up top leave it there yeah yeah yeah
and finding that as a kid being like I
know where one is [__] have to jump
up or get a chair [__] pop it open
catch your parents doing
it get out of here get off of her you
son of a [__] she was wearing her
[__] leggings what do you want from
me
well we got to wrap it up gang gang I'm
going to tell you this right now I'm
going to tell the two of you don't tell
me nothing we love you to death and
we'll see you next week peace peace